es war ein friedliches leben auf der
kleinen insel lummerland bis eines tages
der film hat eine hohe hypothek darin
das ist ein fantastisches buch gibt und
eine sehr lustige vierteilige
marionetten version und man merkt es dem
film auch an dass er dagegen arbeitet
ersetzt vor allem die mittel ein die der
film eben heute hat animation großes
kino chinesische stadt mandala mit mit
herrlichen dekorativen motiven
das problem ist ein bisschen dass es
dabei auch schon sein bewenden hat sich
die geschichte selber die dialoge der
ganze witz der geschichte gerät ein
bisschen in den hintergrund
das wird wohl das land der tausend
ricaner sein
sieht so aus der film geht vielleicht
den irrtum zu glauben dass er eine
fantasy-geschichte hier verfilmt wird
weil es diese wunderbaren elemente gibt
die drachen die todes schlucht und all
diese dinge aber das ist kein fantasy um
rein das geht nicht darum überbordende
fantasie zu schildern sondern das ist
ein ja fast wie ein schulbuch michael
ende schreibt eigentlich ein buch in dem
den kindern unfassbar viel erklärt
werden immer wieder gesagt hat das ist
ein kolibri eine fata morgana
funktioniert übrigens so
also das ist eigentlich eine sehr
erziehen das sehr fast belehrendes buch
im kontrast zu dieser schule hölle die
dann am ende gezeigt wird und die
richtige antwort
eigentlich führt das plus vor wie man
lernen kann und das hat nichts mit einem
hobbys zu tun und nichts mit nicht mit
drachen und hielt einfach nur da sind
was ist meins große tiere sind also das
ist meiner ansicht nach ein bisschen der
der fehler den die machen in der
produktion ein fehler den sie vielleicht
nicht herumkommen wenn man es überhaupt
macht im film heute wird man zu machen
aber es passt gar nicht also da hätten
sie eben die andere geschichten
betrachten verfilmen können das wäre
viel adäquater gewesen die eigenen worte
des kinderbuches kommt im film
eigentlich nicht mehr vor am witzigsten
ist der film in den szenen mit dem
drachen insbesondere den halbdrachen
nepomuk das sind dann animationen im
film selber woran man sieht dass die
puppenwelt doch die angemessenste wählt
ist für die wiedergabe so gut
menschen halten einen wichtigen hinweis
das passt einfach sehr gut wenn es alles
puppen wären und man sieht es in den
drachen szenen am besten
die können ja nicht die können ja nur
animiert seine im film und das
funktioniert sehr hübsch und ist sehr
wichtig dieser film ist eigentlich für
alle für eltern und für kinder
man macht keine fehler wenn man da
hinein geht und doch bleibt irgendwie so
der eindruck
im buch stand irgendwie mir drin
es ist könnte gefährlich werden kein
mensch weiß was uns da draußen erwartet
das macht nichts ich war schon auf dich
auf
[Musik]